l'alcool fait faire des conneries enfin
pas tout le monde heureusement mais il
est clair qu'ils modifient notre
comportement et notre jugement
mais il n'ya pas que l'alcool ou les
drogues qui peuvent modifier nos actions
nous décision il ya aussi tout
simplement les hormones qui sont
naturellement présentes dans nos
organismes
aujourd'hui dans crétin de cerveau on se
fait un petit tour d'horizon de ces
substances chimiques qui viennent
perturber la façon dont on prend nos
décisions
[Musique]
parmi les substances chimiques qui
affectent de manière visible notre
comportement l'alcool est certainement
le plus répandu et ça fait un moment
puisque les plus anciennes traces de
boissons fermentées dont on dispose
remonte à il ya environ dix mille ans et
même certains chimpanzés en consommerait
en milieu naturel
pour commencer il faut savoir que la
consommation et les effets de l'alcool
ont été très étudiée par les chercheurs
ça peut se comprendre vu les problèmes
que pose l alcool sur le plan de la
diction mais aussi des accidents de la
route des comportements violents ou
risqués comme par exemple des relations
sexuelles non protégées
alors il est difficile ici de résumer
toute la littérature scientifique sur le
sujet mais bon je vais essayer d'en
donner quelques résultats principaux
tout d'abord les effets qu'ont
attribuent traditionnellement à l'alcool
ressortent effectivement dans les études
en laboratoire
c'est prouvé scientifiquement l'alcool
joue par exemple à un rôle sur notre
capacité à contrôler nos mouvements
mais il affecte aussi notre mémoire
notre capacité d'attention et notre
humeur sur le plan social l'alcool à un
effet désinhibant ils favorisent
l'excitation sexuelle mais aussi les
comportements violents
bon il est probable qu'en disant cela je
vous apprennent pas grand chose ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant surtout avec ses études
c'est de pouvoir mettre des chiffres sur
ces phénomènes mais a quand même
quelques effets un peu moins intuitif
que les chercheurs ont découvert en 2003
une étude a mesuré l'impact de l'alcool
sur le jugement qu'on porte sur le
physique des autres des sujets ayant bu
ou pas de l'alcool
regardez les photos de personnes qui ne
connaissaient pas et ils devaient leur
attribuer une note d'attractivité et
ceux qui avaient bu mettaient
systématiquement des meilleures notes
que les autres mais uniquement aux
personnes de sexe opposé
alors je suis sûr que sur la base de
votre expérience proche ou personnel
vous doutez pas des effets de l'alcool
sur notre organisme
mais dans les années 70 et 80 des
chercheurs se sont demandés s'il n'y
avait pas une part psychologique de
l'effet de l'alcool
et si on pouvait pas tout simplement
reproduire certains de ses effets en
donnant un placebo pour tester cette
idée est bien séparer les effets
physiques d effet placebo ils ont
imaginé un protocole particulier chaque
fois qu'on veut faire une étude il faut
diviser les participants en quatre
groupes un groupe à qui on dit qu'il
reçoit de l'alcool et qui en reçoit
effectivement généralement un mélange de
vodka est tonique un groupe à qui on
fait croire qu'il en reçoit mais qui
reçoit un placebo c'est à dire juste du
tonique un groupe à qui on dit qu'il
reçoit que du tonique et c'est
effectivement ce qu'on lui donne et
enfin un groupe anti placebo à qui on
fait croire qu'il va recevoir juste du
tonique mais dans lequel on ajoute de la
vodka en douce alors faire ce genre
d'expérience et pas simple et rassurez
vous tout est bien encadré et contrôlé
mais pour que la supercherie de l'effet
placebo fonctionne il faut toute une
mise en scène les expériences se passe
dans une pièce qui reproduit le décor
d'un bar un serveur prépare les boissons
devant les sujets avec de vraies
bouteilles d'eau tonique et de votre
carte pour les mettre dans l'ambiance
évidemment le contenu des bouteilles est
truqué selon les besoins de l'expérience
et en plus de ça les chercheurs ont
recours à tout un tas de subterfuges et
un notamment pour les groupes à qui on
doit mentir donc par exemple pour le
groupe à qui on fait croire qu'il reçoit
de l'alcool alors qu'il n'en reçoit pas
on est obligé de vaporiser de l'alcool
sur le vert pour reproduire l'odeur
caractéristique
grâce à ce type de protocole les
chercheurs ont bien pu séparer ce qui
est l effet physique pharmacologique de
l'alcool de tout ce qui relève de
l'effet placebo
figurez-vous que l'effet placebo est
énorme ce qu'on constate c'est que pour
les effets vraiment physique comme le
contrôle des muscles l'attention bien la
capacité à traiter de l'information le
rôle de l'alcool est bien réelle mais
pour tous les comportements qu'on peut
qualifier de sociaux comme l'excitation
sexuelle ou l'agressivité qu'on vous
donne de l'alcool ou bien qu'on vous
donne un placebo en vous en croire que
c'est l'alcool le résultat est le même
il ya plusieurs études de ce genre mais
je vous en détail une on a soumis des
sujets à une expérience selon protocole
dont j'ai parlé donc avec quatre groupes
et ensuite on leur a donné accès à des
images sous forme de diapositives chaque
personne voyait 24 images qui était de
quatre types différents
des images neutre des images érotiques
des images violentes et enfin des images
à la fois érotique et violente
les participants contre les librement
quand passer d'une diapositive à l'autre
et donc il pouvait regarder chaque image
autant qu'il le voulait et on a mesuré
le temps moyen qui passait sur chaque
type d'image et voici les résultats
si on compare tous ceux qui ont reçu de
l'alcool et tous ceux qui n'en ont pas
reçu
indépendamment de ce qu'on leur a dit on
ne voit pas de grosses différences dans
les temps passés
on voit qu'ils préfèrent les images à
caractère érotique ok mais le fait
d'avoir bu de l'alcool n'a pas eu une
influence
par contre si on compare ceux à qui on a
dit qu'ils allaient recevoir l'alcool et
ceux à qui on a dit qu'ils allaient
juste recevoir du tonique
on constate une différence nette le fait
de croire à tort ou à raison qu'ils
avaient bu de l'alcool leur faisait
passer plus de temps sur les images
érotiques et ou violente
le temps passé à regarder ces images et
donc pas influencé par la prise d'alcool
mais par la croyance qu'on en a bu c'est
un effet placebo
l'interprétation de ce résultat par les
chercheurs c'est que pour des
comportements qui sont considérés comme
socialement moins acceptable comme
l'attirance pour la violence ou pour le
sexe le fait de croire qu'on a bu de
l'alcool
nous donne une sorte d' excuses et donc
nous désinhibe indépendamment de l'effet
réel de l'alcool mais voyons maintenant
une autre manifestation assez amusante
de l'effet placebo
[Musique]
en 2012 une équipe française a fait une
expérience dans un bar où ils ont
demandé à des gens de se noter eux mêmes
sur une échelle de 1 à 7 pour dire à
quel point il se trouve est attractif
brillant originaux et drôle et ensuite
ils ont corréler les notes que les gens
s'auto-attribue et avec leur alcoolémie
et devinez quoi
et bien plus on a bu plus on se met à
soi même de meilleures notes
mais pour bien séparer les faits réels
de l'effet placebo
ils ont dû faire une expérience un peu
mieux contrôler ils ont réuni 94
participants et ils ont utilisé toujours
le même type de protocole où on fait
quatre groupes en fonction de ce qu'on
leur annonce et de ce qu'on leur donne
vraiment après avoir consommé leurs
boissons les participants devaient créer
un petit speech sur un thème
publicitaire imposé et venir le jouer
sur une scène où il était filmé à la fin
on leur repasser le film et on leur
demandait de noter leurs propres
prestations et voici les notes moyennes
que se sont attribués les gens dans les
quatre groupes et on voit que les
meilleures notes sont celles des
participants qui pensait avoir reçu de
l'alcool et ce indépendamment du fait
qu'ils en aient effectivement bu ou pas
alors à ce stade il ya deux hypothèses
soit le fait de croire qu'ils ont reçues
l'alcool a poussé leur jugement soit
leur prestation était effectivement
objectivement meilleur c'est à dire le
fait de croire qu'on a reçues de
l'alcool nous rend meilleurs orateurs
mais bon en fait c'est pas ça pour le
savoir les chercheurs ont fait aussi
noter les prestations par un panel de
personnes indépendantes et agen et là il
y avait pas de différence entre les
quatre groupes
c'est que l'effet placebo joue bien sur
notre propre auto évaluation et pas sur
la qualité de ce qu'on produit une des
questions les plus importantes qu'on se
pose au sujet de l'alcool et des plus
difficiles aussi concerne ses liens avec
les comportements risqués
est-ce que l'alcool nous fait prendre
plus de risques et la question n'est pas
simple parce qu'il n'est pas évident
d'interpréter les données existantes
prenant l'exemple classique d accidents
de la route on sait qu en état d'ébriété
ont conduit moins bien et donc on va
avoir plus d'accidents mais en plus de
ça est ce qu'il y aura un effet
supplémentaire de l'alcool qui nous
ferait prendre plus de risques
inconsidérés la difficulté pour trancher
scientifiquement la question c'est qu'il
est évidemment pas simple de réaliser
des expériences pour tester notre
propension à prendre plus de risques
sous l'influencé de l'alcool
mais il ya au moins un domaine dans
lequel on a pu le faire c'est celui des
risques économiques
je vous ai déjà parlé dans un épisode
précédent de la série crétin de cerveau
de ce qu'on appelle l'aversion au risque
c'est le fait que si je vous donne le
choix entre toucher 100 euros ou toucher
300 euros mais à seulement une chance
sur deux là une majorité de gens
préfèrent qu'on la première option celle
qui n'est pas risqué même
si en moyenne la deuxième est plus
intéressante la plupart des humains ont
une aversion au risque
la question que se sont posés des
chercheurs c'est de savoir si l'alcool
diminue notre aversion au risque et donc
nous ferait courir plus de risques
du moins sur un problème économique
comme celui ci et bien la réponse est
non sur les expériences qu'ils ont mené
la prise d'alcool ne diminue pas
significativement l'aversion au risque
et même chez les femmes elle a un peu
tendance à l'augmenter c'est-à-dire à
les rendre plus prudente
cette question est intéressant dans le
contexte notamment des jeux d'argent on
sait qu'à une table de casino ou poker
on boit pas que du sirop est ce qu'il
peut y avoir un lien entre la
consommation d'alcool et la prise de
risque au jeu et bien d'après cette
étude pas de manière claire
en revanche on connaît une substance
chimique dont on sait qu'elle a un
impact dans ce genre de situation c'est
la dopamine
[Musique]
la dopamine c'est un neurotransmetteur
c'est à dire une petite molécule qui est
libéré au niveau des synapses qui sont
les points de communication entre les
neurones on sait que la dopamine joue
notamment un rôle dans la motivation est
dans la manière dont le cerveau se
récompense lui-même et on sait aussi que
la maladie de parkinson qui se
caractérise par des problèmes de
contrôle des mouvements s'accompagnent
de la perte de certains neurones qui
normalement secrète de la dopamine est
donc un des traitements pour soigner les
symptômes de la maladie de parkinson
c'est justement de donner de la dopamine
enfin pas directement de la dopamine
parce qu'elle ne pourrait pas franchir
la barrière hémato-encéphalique celle
qui permet de passer du sang au cerveau
du coup on donne soit des molécules qui
lui ressemble on parle d'agonistes et
qui sont capables d'activer les mêmes
récepteurs tout en passant la barrière
soit de la l dopa qui est un précurseur
de la dopamine
c'est à dire une molécule que notre
cerveau saura ensuite transformé en
dopamine
ces traitements de la maladie de
parkinson sont très répandus mais avec
certaines molécules et sur certains
patients on a constaté des effets
secondaires très spectaculaire et
franchement handicapant le traitement
provoque chez eux une forte addiction au
jeu et parfois au sexe ça reste
heureusement des cas assez rare mais des
chercheurs se sont demandés si la
dopamine pouvait avoir une influence sur
la prise de risque au-delà de ces
patients dans la population générale
pour ça ils ont pris des sujets et ils
l'auront peut faire des expériences dans
deux conditions une première où il
recevait un placebo et une deuxième fois
où il recevait de la l dopa dans ces
expériences il était soumis à une série
de décisions sous forme de jeu où à
chaque fois ils avaient le choix entre
deux options une option certaine où on
gagne à une quantité fixe d'argent et
une option risquée ou lazard intervenait
et ils ont constaté que dans
l'expérience où il avait reçu de la l
dopa les sujets prenait plus souvent un
choix risqué que dans l'expérience où il
avait reçu un placebo et plus on
augmente la dose de l dopa plus l'effet
est prononcé même si pour être honnête
les faits et pas non plus énorme
alors voyons maintenant une autre
substance pour laquelle les faits et
cette fois indéniable la testostérone la
testostérone c'est une hormone sexuelle
qui est impliquée dans le développement
des organes sexuels mâles chez la
plupart des vertébrés
elle est secrétaire par les testicules
même si les ovaires des femelles en
produisent aussi dans la nature des taux
de testostérone plus élevé que la
moyenne sont notamment retrouvés chez
les mâles dominants et chez les hommes
la testostérone a des liens démontrés
avec le comportement sexuel ou même
simplement dans le couple par exemple
pour une même tranche d'âge les hommes
avec des niveaux de testostérone élevé
sont moins
souvent mariés plus souvent divorcé et
trompe plus souvent leurs femmes
mais comme pour l'alcool ou la dopamine
des chercheurs ont voulu évaluer son
impact sur les décisions économiques
notamment qu'il ya un élément
d'interactions sociales pour ça ils ont
utilisé ce qu'on appelle le jeu de
l'ultimatum
le principe est le suivant on a deux
joueurs qui vont occuper un rôle
différent on met une certaine somme au
milieu de la table disons 40 euros le
premier joueur doit proposer un partage
de cette somme entre les deux par
exemple il propose 25 pour lui et 15
pour l'autre est le deuxième joueur doit
décider s'il accepte le deal ou pas
s'ils acceptent mal argent est
effectivement partagé de cette manière
mais s'il refuse l'argent disparaît et
personne ne gagne rien et dans tous les
cas on ne fait qu'un tour après ça le
jeu se termine et il n'y a pas de
négociation possible c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça le jeu de l'ultimatum alors
analysons rationnellement ce jeu le
deuxième joueur a le choix entre prendre
l'argent qu'on lui propose ou refusé le
deal auquel cas ils touchent rien
l'attitude rationnelle pour lui c'est
donc normalement d'accepter le deal quel
qu'il soit même si l'autre joueur
propose pas grand chose mais sachant
cela le premier joueur lui un intérêt à
proposer un partage vraiment inéquitable
et a proposé le minimum possible au
second joueur puisque celui ci est censé
accepter tout ça c'est le raisonnement
rationnel mais dans la réalité ça se
passe pas du tout comme ça ceux qui sont
dans la position du premier joueur vont
assez fréquemment proposer un partage
relativement équitable même si
rationnellement il serait pas obligé
quant à ceux qui sont dans la position
du second joueur
eh bien ils vont parfois refuser une
offre qui leur paraît injuste quitte à
se sacrifier
parce que du coup ils préfèrent ne rien
toucher que de toucher le résultat d'un
partage injuste
un chercheur de l'université de harvard
terrance burnham a fait une expérience
en utilisant ce jeu il a recruté des
hommes et les a fait jouer mais
uniquement dans la position du deuxième
joueur celui qui décide d'accepter ou de
refuser la proposition mais le premier
joueur était en fait un complice qui
proposait systématiquement de partager
les 40 dollars en 35 $ pour lui et cinq
dollars pour le sujet d'expérience mais
en am a classé les sujets suivants qui
les accepter ou rejeter cette offre
plutôt inéquitable et il a mesuré
ensuite leur taux de testostérone et la
grosse différence
les hommes qui avaient refusé l'offre
avait un niveau de testostérone 50% plus
élevé que les autres
hélas quantitativement le résultat est
très nette
mais il faut quand même être un peu
prudent dans l'interprétation on
démontre qu'il ya une corrélation entre
le niveau de testostérone et le fait de
10 ans
être agressif dans les échanges
économiques mais ça veut pas dire qu'il
ya un lien de cause à effet par exemple
on pourrait imaginer qu'il ya un
troisième facteur des prédispositions
génétiques par exemple qui influencent à
la fois le niveau de testostérone et le
comportement économique
d'ailleurs une étude ultérieure a montré
que sur des femmes ménopausées
le fait de leur administrer la
testostérone était sans effet sur ce
type de décision donc c'est pas
forcément juste en vogue avant de
testostérone que vous allez devenir le
loup de wall street
mais passons maintenant à une autre
hormone qui a beaucoup fait parler
d'elle ces dernières années l'ocytocine
l'ocytocine est une hormone qui est
impliqué dans les comportements
maternelle notamment au cours de
l'accouchement et pendant l'allaitement
et on lui attribue aussi un rôle dans
les comportements d'empathie en 2005 un
groupe de chercheurs a publié une étude
visant à étudier les effets de
l'ocytocine sur certains comportements
sociaux et ils ont eux aussi utiliser un
jeu économique mais différent le jeu de
l'investisseur dans ce jeu on prend deux
joueurs
le premier sera l'investisseur et le
second est appelé le dépositaire au
début du jeu l'investisseur reçoit une
somme d'argent par exemple 10 euros et
il a le choix d'en conserver une partie
est d'investir l'autre mettons qu'il
garde 4 euros et qu'ils investissent 6
la somme investie est triplée par la
banque est remise au second joueur le
dépositaire ici reçoit par exemple 18
euros est le dépositaire doit décider
alors du partage de cet argent entre les
deux joueurs
par exemple qui peut décider de garder
10 pour lui est de redonner 8 à
l'investisseur l'intérêt de ce jeu c'est
qui permet de mesurer une notion de
confiance de la part du premier joueur
alors faisons à nouveau une analyse
purement rationnelle de la situation
le second joueur d'un point de vue
strictement égoïste a intérêt à tout
garder pour lui et à ne pas rendre
l'argent est donc le premier joueur
l'investisseur sachant cela a intérêt à
ne rien lui confier du tout sauf qu'en
pratique le premier joueur a quand même
tendance à investir une partie de la
somme en faisant confiance au second
joueur pour qu'il lui en rendent une
part suffisante et en utilisant ce jeu
de l'investisseur l'équipe de cosfa ldc
collaborateurs à mesurer à quel point la
confiance c'est à dire les choix
effectués par le premier joueur était
influencé par le fait qu'on ait pris de
l'ocytocine bien un placebo et là ils
ont vu un effet assez spectaculaire
l'investisseur ayant reçu de l'ocytocine
par voie nasale avant le jeu a beaucoup
plus tendance à faire confiance que
celui qui a reçu un placebo
en particulier il ya une proportion très
significative de ceux qui ont pris le
site hocine qui choisissent de courir le
ce que maximum et d'investir
l'intégralité de la somme pour la
confier aux dépositaires
à ce stade on pourrait se dire que
l'ocytocine brouille simplement les
raisonnements comme l'alcool ou bien
fait courir plus de risques comme la
dopamine
mais pour écarter cette hypothèse les
chercheurs ont fait une autre expérience
où cette fois le deuxième joueur le
dépositaire et est remplacé par un
ordinateur c'est à dire qu'il y avait
plus de relations humaines et là l'effet
positif de l'ocytocine sur la confiance
qu'accorde le premier joueur disparaît
leur interprétation c'est donc que
l'ocytocine ne brûle pas les
comportements et n'augmente pas la prise
de risque mais elle augmente la notion
de confiance quand il ya une interaction
sociale
les résultats de cette expérience ont
été assez médiatisée notamment par un
des auteurs de l'étude paul zac qui en a
fait un peu son fonds de commerce et a
commencé à écrire des livres et donner
des conférences pour expliquer qu'il
avait découvert l'hormone de l'amour
la molécule de la morale et c'est
l'américaine quoi mais comme toujours il
faut relativiser les études qui ont été
faites ultérieurement montré que le rôle
de l'ocytocine était peut-être pas si
nette mêmes qui pouvait être un peu
ambiguë par exemple l'ocytocine
favoriserait le sentiment d'appartenance
à un groupe et donc augmenterait
l'agressivité envers ceux qui ne font
pas partie du groupe
bref l'ocytocine a certainement un rôle
sur notre comportement après tout c'est
une hormone naturelle mais méfiez vous
des gros titres qui lui attribue des
vertus à un peu trop simpliste
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo comme
d'habitude un abonné vous appuyez sur la
cloche laïque et tout ça
si vous voulez des news de la chaîne
vous pouvez me suivre sur twitter ou sur
facebook et ceux qui le souhaitent
peuvent le soutenir sur tipi merci à
bientôt
[Musique]